Leur terrain de jeu, l'océan Pacifique.
Dominant un si vaste royaume,
ils découpent une silhouette trop familière.
Leur réputation populaire
comme de féroces prédateurs est compréhensible.
Pourtant, que sont-ils, sinon des charognards communs?
Un humble éboueur des mers
et trop souvent
déjoués par leurs cadets.
Voici des requins dans leurs vraies couleurs.
Le Pacifique est de loin le plus grand corps
d'eau sur la planète.
Couvrant 70 millions de miles carrés,
ça compte pour la moitié
la surface des océans du monde.
Perdu dans ce royaume bleu,
piqûres de terre
où les jeunes oiseaux de mer
sont sur le point de quitter leur nid
pour la première fois.
Un fait pas perdu sur la vie sous le récif
qui encercle les petites îles
des French Frigate Shoals
dans le nord-ouest d'Hawaï.
Après des semaines d'entraînement,
poussins d'albatros à pieds noirs
sont prêts pour le grand jour.
Leurs parents sont déjà partis
le terrain de nidification.
Même le vent fort
soufflant du lagon
ne peut pas aider celui-ci.
C'est un jeu équitable
pour le prédateur le plus opportuniste
dans le lagon, le requin tigre.
C'est à la fois imprévisible
et extrêmement agressif.
Contrairement à d'autres espèces de requins en mer,
le requin tigre est généralement un solitaire
dont les terrains de chasse préférés
sont les bas-fonds.
Rien de tel qu'un coup de pouce
dans la bonne direction pour décoller.
Ce ne devait pas être le cas.
Les poussins essaieront de décoller à l'unisson.
Le requin tigre
n'a qu'une fenêtre d'opportunité étroite
pour jouer, se régaler
et sauver sa formidable réputation.
En pleine mer, requins et oiseaux
se comporter d'une manière tout à fait différente.
Chaque type de nomade de l'océan
est attiré par les vents et les courants forts
qui galvanisent la mer
dans un tourbillon d'intérêts concurrents,
à la fois au-dessus et au-dessous de la surface.
Alors, comment sont ces eaux d'opale vierges
géré ou entretenu, si vous préférez?
Contrairement au requin tigre
surveiller seul les eaux peu profondes,
les nomades ici travaillent ensemble
vers un objectif commun,
que ce soit pour la défense ou l'attaque.
Bancs de poissons-appâts
se regrouper pour se protéger.
Ils sont rassemblés
par un groupe de grands dauphins.
La table est mise.
Attendez un moment.
Des invités inattendus se sont présentés,
et les dauphins doivent quitter la table.
Requins soyeux.
Ils ont regardé
les dauphins travaillent à distance.
Leur vision finement accordée
à la pénombre bleue
à cause de pigments spéciaux dans leurs yeux.
Les dauphins attendent sagement
pour une deuxième séance,
qu'ils partageront
avec d'autres en surface.
Fous de Bassan et pétrels bruns
profiter d'une vue plongeante,
mais leur patience s'épuise.
Maintenant que les eaux ont été testées,
un bombardement aérien complet est en cours.
Ces torpilles à plumes
faut grimper à dix mètres
avant d'exécuter
leurs sorties spectaculaires.
Cette agression extraordinaire
par requin et oiseau
contre les appâts désorientés
est implacable.
Ayant pris la part du lion,
les requins soyeux se retirent
aussi volontairement qu'ils sont venus.
C'est un moment de répit pour les poissons-appâts.
Mais pas pour longtemps.
L'albacore forme un troisième front,
vague après vague d'entre eux.
C'est de la prédation à grande échelle.
Les appâts restants
avoir une dernière carte à jouer.
Ils grouillent de requins soyeux individuels,
pas pour se venger,
mais pour la protection contre le thon.
Les poissons-appâts sont confrontés à un dilemme.
Devraient-ils passer du requin au thon?
Le silence de ce monde prédateur
parle pour lui-même.
Il y a des régions du Pacifique
où les prédateurs naturels
se tourner vers le nettoyage pour gagner sa vie.
L'île principale
dans l'archipel de Nouvelle-Calédonie
est une bande de terre dans le Pacifique Sud,
250 milles de long et 30 de large.
Les petites îles se baignent
dans les eaux cristallines
d'un lagon tropical.
Le plus grand lagon du monde,
9 000 milles carrés.
C'est un paradis méticuleusement entretenu
par ceux qui l'habitent.
Aucun paradis n'est sans sacrifice.
Ceux qui le partagent
partager les uns les autres aussi.
Partout la vie prospère,
la mort récoltera une juste récompense.
Le lagon crée des déchets
et doit en disposer.
Un jour, les morts et les blessés
sera épongé par les charognards,
les éboueurs des mers.
Le lagon n'est pas impénétrable.
Les fissures sont ouvertes
dans ce vaste anneau de corail
par le martèlement incessant de l'océan.
Le requin pointe blanche
est un briseur de barrage expert.
Un vivaneau rouge pris au piège dans un filet.
Le requin se concentre sur les signaux de détresse
comme le vivaneau émet
une faible charge électrique
même quand il est immobile.
Littéralement un millionième de volt
est suffisant pour stimuler les organes sensoriels
appelé Ampoules de Lorenzini
sur le museau du requin.
En effet, les blessés et les faibles
signer leur propre arrêt de mort.
Un requin gris de récif
s'approche des pointes blanches industrieuses,
désireux de se joindre à l'opération Clean Up.
Sa taille impressionnante ne lui vaut pas
le droit automatique de se muscler.
C'est une soirée privée
pour les pointes blanches uniquement.
Les requins eux-mêmes courent également le risque
de se faire prendre dans des filets,
en particulier ceux plus utilisés
habiter la haute mer.
Mais les requins à pointes blanches
sont équipés de deux rangées de dents.
Les dessus sont triangulés et dentelés,
la rangée inférieure, étroite et pointue.
Une combinaison parfaite pour couper
et se sortir des ennuis.
Les dents abîmées seront remplacées dans 18 jours,
et ils pousseront environ 20 000 nouvelles dents
au cours de leur vie.
Tant que les requins de récif
se déplacer librement et chasser en meute,
ni filets ni autres requins
les arrêtera dans leur mission
nettoyer le lagon
de poissons blessés et affaiblis.
Par inadvertance, les requins vont même aider
démanteler ces filets destructeurs.
Ce vivaneau pourrait s'estimer chanceux,
si seulement il pouvait cacher sa détresse.
Plus il lutte pour rester à flot,
plus le signal est fort.
Grâce au radar naturel du requin
et sa capacité à détecter les vibrations
de loin, la zone est dégagée.
Poches de grottes coralliennes et calcaires
offrent une certaine isolation de ce radar,
qu'il faut dire
n'est utilisé qu'à courte portée.
C'est quoi celui-ci après ?
Un labre nageur
qui émet des vibrations à longue portée.
Whitetips ira très loin
pour satisfaire leur appétit.
Ou est-ce juste de la curiosité ?
Après tout, ils ont besoin
ne nourrir que tous les deux jours
et à peine 3% de leur poids corporel
est considéré comme un assez bon repas.
Certains vont chercher à l'embouchure d'une grotte
par une cassure dans le récif,
un bon endroit pour une embuscade.
Contrairement à leurs cousins en eau libre,
les pointes blanches n'ont pas besoin
être en mouvement pour respirer.
Ils peuvent guetter leur proie
en utilisant des contractions musculaires
pour pomper l'eau par leurs branchies.
Ces mâles
n'ont pas faim de nourriture, mais de sexe.
Ils attendent une femelle.
Elle est cernée de tous côtés
par des mâles concurrents,
mais l'amant
doit repousser d'autres rivaux excités.
L'amour
durera environ cinq minutes.
Pendant quelle période
le prétendant doit repousser d'autres rivaux
entraîné dans la scène
par les vibrations et les impulsions électriques
rayonnant de la parade nuptiale.
La femelle s'en est probablement tirée légèrement.
Celui-ci a peu de chances de survivre.
Son sang signale involontairement
sa condition vulnérable
à tous les voleurs de la région,
dont le plus gros poisson du monde.
Le requin baleine.
Il mesure 15 mètres de long et est tout à fait inoffensif.
Comme de vraies baleines,
le requin baleine est un filtre
utilisant ses mâchoires caverneuses
aspirer du plancton
et autres menues frites sur son passage.
C'est aussi un nettoyant des plus efficaces,
bien qu'incapable
de nettoyer un requin mourant.
Agitation, sang, électricité,
les signaux de détresse révélateurs
rayonne haut et fort.
Ce silvertip a élu domicile dans
du bas du col.
Un comité d'accueil vous attend,
les vivaneaux rouges sont de retour,
ainsi que les requins gris de récif.
Ces grands dauphins de passage
et leurs mollets
éviter le danger.
Un silvertip de cette taille est également
une menace potentielle pour les bébés dauphins.
Le requin doit être vu.
En effet, les dauphins se relaient
remonter à la surface pour respirer.
La tactique est ingénieuse.
Les dauphins tournent autour du silvertip
pour le forcer à se mettre hors de danger.
Des renforts sont appelés
pour augmenter la pression.
C'est maintenant cinq contre un
et le silvertip obtient enfin le point.
Les dauphins ne peuvent cacher leur joie.
Il est temps de faire surface et de célébrer.
La passe à travers le récif est maintenant dégagée
et les dauphins sont libres d'entrer
les bas-fonds et explorer les eaux
autour des îles sablonneuses.
Alors que le printemps se transforme en été
dans l'hémisphère sud,
un pèlerinage séculaire
est sur le point de s'échouer sur ces rivages.
Même heure, même endroit.
Une tortue verte marquée par un long voyage.
Les sains
perpétuera l'espèce
comme ils le font depuis 15 millions d'années.
Un rendez-vous annuel pour l'accouplement
et pour que les femelles pondent des œufs.
L'événement est également au calendrier
du requin pointe noire.
A marée haute, il regarde avidement
pendant que les femelles se préparent à s'échouer.
Les tortues solitaires ont traversé
le Pacifique avec une extrême précision.
Merci, c'est pensé,
à certains minéraux magnétiques dans leur cerveau
qui puisent dans la Terre
champ magnétique pour la direction.
La marée remplit les piscines naturelles
autour du rocher de la plage
permettant aux requins de s'approcher du rivage.
Une femelle, tous les 80 livres d'elle,
transporte ses oeufs
loin de la ligne des hautes eaux,
plus d'un kilomètre à l'intérieur des terres.
Les requins connaissent la routine.
Ils patrouilleront les piscines
jusqu'à ce que la marée les chasse à nouveau.
Les tortues ont 12 heures
creuser et remplir leurs nids
avant d'attraper la prochaine marée haute.
Alors que la marée se retire,
les crabes de sable creusent aussi
pour une nuit de chasse.
Alors que la nuit tombe,
des pointes noires frôlent encore le rivage.
Requins gris de récif
patrouiller plus loin en mer.
Un blocus est en place.
Avec la marée maintenant basse,
quelques tortues
ont fini de pondre leurs œufs.
Une couverture de sable
les gardera à une température constante
et les cacher des prédateurs
pendant une période d'incubation de deux mois.
Les femelles commencent maintenant
le pénible voyage de retour.
Au matin,
la plupart sont partis à marée haute.
Ceux qui l'ont raté
doit faire face à un mur punitif
de coraux exposés sous le soleil brûlant,
le tout après une nuit de travail épuisante.
C'est la fin du chemin pour celui-ci.
Sa carcasse pue maintenant
d'huiles riches et de chair déchirée.
Au signal, récifs gris et pointes noires
suivre leur nez.
Pour localiser des proies mortes,
ces charognards sont guidés
par leur odorat.
Bernard-l'ermite reclus
sont laissés pour polir l'argent.
Au milieu de l'été, la saison sèche s'installe
sur l'île principale de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Une chaîne de montagnes sur la côte sous le vent
crée de longues périodes de sécheresse.
C'est à la maison
à des dizaines de milliers de cerfs sauvages
qui cherchent maintenant ailleurs de verts pâturages.
Certains se dirigent vers les mangroves.
Beaucoup quitteront complètement l'île
et s'aventurer à travers la baie
à la recherche de nourriture sur d'autres îles.
Leurs sabots étroits
sont peu adaptés à la baignade.
Espérons que la flottabilité naturelle
de leur panse les maintiendra à flot.
Le cerf peut en moyenne
deux nœuds sur de longues distances
simplement en répétant
les mêmes mouvements qu'ils utilisent sur terre.
À travers le lagon dans n'importe quelle direction
se trouvent des dizaines de minuscules îles inhabitées.
Ils sont épais avec des herbes et du feuillage
alimenté toute l'année en eau douce
emprisonné dans le sous-sol calcaire.
La traversée en valait la peine,
même si certains cerfs
ont lutté à deux milles du continent
trouver de nouvelles aires d'alimentation.
Ils passeront tout l'été
d'île en île pour survivre à la sécheresse.
Chaque jour apporte de nouveaux arrivages.
Ce gamin est épuisé,
mais au moins il a réussi.
Beaucoup meurent en cours de route.
Déchets à éliminer
par les éboueurs des mers.
Un simple sang d'une partie
à 100 millions de parties d'eau
suffit à déclencher une frénésie.
A la fin de l'été,
la dernière des tortues nicheuses
quittent les îles.
Des centaines d'œufs sont prêts à éclore.
Instinctivement, les bébés tortues
direction la piscine.
Il n'y a pas d'odeur de sang cette fois.
Ici, les pointes noires doivent utiliser leurs yeux
si leur patience doit être récompensée.
C'est un problème
parce qu'ils sont myopes
et leurs mouvements
sont à l'étroit par les eaux peu profondes.
Dans l'éventualité,
les requins sont rejoints par d'autres,
prédateurs plus rapides et plus efficaces.
Carangue géante,
plus communément appelé Jack.
Livre pour livre,
c'est le poisson le plus fort du monde,
requins inclus.
C'est parfaitement adapté
au limpide,
et des bas-fonds bien oxygénés.
C'est la preuve.
En revanche, il faut
deux pointes noires myopes et maladroites
chasser un seul bébé tortue.
Ceux qui ont survécu
le blocus en pleine mer
doit maintenant lutter
avec des prédateurs venus du ciel.
Avec ces sternes, ces requins et ces carangues,
il n'est pas étonnant que sur 100 œufs,
une seule tortue survivra jusqu'à l'âge adulte.
Si c'est l'un d'entre eux,
il sera de retour dans 15 ans
pour s'accoupler ou pondre des œufs.
Les charognards feront
un point d'être là aussi.
Pour l'essentiel, la vie autour du lagon
est tout à fait prévisible.
Voici une magnifique exception.
Une baleine bleue de 18 mètres,
le plus gros animal
jamais parcourir la planète.
A la fin de l'été austral,
ce mâle devrait se nourrir
sur le krill en Antarctique,
mais il a perdu son chemin
et mystérieusement récupéré dans le lagon.
Jamais cela n'a été vu
auparavant en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Les vergetures sont des signes
de sous-alimentation sévère.
Si le lagon ne peut satisfaire ses besoins,
peut-être que cela peut satisfaire les autres.
Quarante tonnes de chair émettent
ondes sonores rapides à basse fréquence.
Le requin tigre a capté le signal
à plusieurs kilomètres
quand la baleine atteint le fond
de la baie, épuisé et acculé.
Au final, il n'y a qu'un seul tueur.
Quel régal.
Rare en effet pour ce requin tigre
d'avoir misé sur tant de viande rouge.
Il s'est poussé à la limite
et a avalé
un dixième de son propre poids corporel.
D'autres requins étaient probablement trop loin
dans le lagon pour arriver à temps.
La baleine bleue ne va pas plus loin.
Jour après jour, le cadavre de la baleine
rayonnera un gigantesque chemin huileux.
les requins
et leur odorat stéréoscopique
suivra simplement
cet escalier vers le ciel.
Ce trésor de protéines
a été frappé par toute une meute de tigres,
et ils ne laisseront pas
toute autre espèce de requin à proximité.
Seuls quelques rémoras inoffensifs sont tolérés.
Le nettoyage final est en cours.
Cela a pris une semaine et ça compte
pour nettoyer les 18 tonnes de viande.
Que peu de preuves
est à gauche de la baleine bleue
filtrera à travers des passes dans le lagon
pour le nettoyage final
dans l'abîme sombre de la pleine mer.
Environ 85% du Pacifique
a plus d'un mile de profondeur,
beaucoup de place pour les autres,
plus de charognards passifs
attendre dans le noir et le froid
et sous une pression colossale
pour les cueillettes
laissés par leurs pairs à la surface.
Ici-bas, la vie existe sans oxygène.
Évents hydrothermaux en haute mer
maintenir une oasis de vie.
Situé au bord d'une faille
entre deux plaques tectoniques,
Nouvelle Calédonie
est effectivement une montagne dans l'océan.
Ces gigantesques fractures de la croûte
éructent des gaz à travers les cheminées du fond marin.
Dans ce monde souterrain anaérobie et instable,
la vie s'organise
autour du méthane et du sulfure d'hydrogène,
très toxique sur terre,
mais de maintien de la vie dans l'abîme.
Au bas de la pile évolutive
dans cet écosystème se trouve le ver tubicole.
Il n'a pas de bouche,
pas de tube digestif et pas d'anus.
Tout passe par ses plumes.
Les évents thermiques super chaleur
l'eau à 350 degrés Celsius,
mais à 3 000 mètres de profondeur,
l'eau ne bout pas.
La pression est trop grande.
Alors les crevettes aveugles sont libres de gratter
les évents pour les minéraux et les bactéries.
C'est remarquable
comment la vie marine peut s'adapter à cet enfer.
Loin des aérations, notamment au pied
du lagon néo-calédonien,
Il n'y a rien.
La vie dans ces déserts abyssaux
dépend essentiellement de ce qui coule
de la surface.
Quand les charognards de l'obscurité
atteindre leur objectif,
des relations
peut durer extrêmement longtemps.
Les crabes géants prendront plusieurs années
nettoyer une carcasse de baleine.
Difficile à repérer
dans ce monde sombre,
à moins que comme un calmar,
vous êtes équipés de photophores,
une sorte d'organe producteur de lumière.
Ils les utilisent pour attirer des proies
ou pour séduire des partenaires sexuels,
mais ces cellules lumineuses
peut également être vu sur les animaux mourants.
D'autres doivent tâtonner
leur chemin autour du fond de l'océan
dans leur recherche
pour la matière organique, morte ou vivante.
C'est une tâche facilitée
pour l'aiguillat commun,
et comme ses cousins du lagon,
son odorat stéréoscopique.
Les autres charognards doivent attendre
pour que les courants leur apportent de la nourriture,
comme ce poisson tripode.
Ils peuvent également filtrer les particules organiques
comme ce concombre de mer qui nage
et ces crinoïdes.
Le calmar vampire utilise
cils sensoriels pour détecter ce qui est comestible
dans la houle de l'océan.
Qu'avons-nous ici ?
Le plat le plus prisé
dans l'abîme, une baleine entière.
Il est couvert de myxines.
Ces fossiles vivants
existent depuis 5 millions d'années,
bien avant tout autre poisson.
Ce sont des vertébrés sans yeux,
pas de squelette, pas d'écailles,
même pas une bouche.
Ils ont un cercle externe de dents
et un fort sens de l'odorat.
Mais un million de myxines ne peuvent pas égaler cela.
Le requin dormeur du Pacifique,
indolent et paresseux de nature,
mais très gourmand.
Long de sept mètres et pesant deux tonnes,
c'est le plus gros de tous les poissons d'eau profonde
et il a un désir insatiable de garder
un estomac de 300 litres confortablement plein.
La plupart de la vie autour du lagon
en Nouvelle-Calédonie finit dans le gouffre.
Même les requins océaniques
sont destinés à devenir un repas
pour les crabes galathées.
Un éboueur en nourrit un autre,
une fin convenable
pour les charognards des mers.